hello everyone and yes the rumors you've
heard have been true levin arnone will
no longer be representing armenia
uh rather he will be uh playing for the
united states and uh
it's uh been the news uh hit the chess
world today
i uh i haven't heard anything about it
before even rumors so i guess it was uh
something that's been cooking for a
while and it's not the first time levin
received offers he received offers many
times and i will put a link in the
description below
to an article on chess 24 where
everything is very nicely
uh explained but uh basically he
received
offers uh many times even uh you know
money wise as it says in the article
even a thousand times more
than he's receiving from from armenia
but he never uh was interested in in
transferring he always wanted to
represent his home country
uh but now as he says uh as of 2018
there's a new government and they have
no interest in chess whatsoever uh and
he decided that he will no longer be
uh re representing armenia and this is
quite
quite an acquisition for the uh team of
the united states uh
he's transferring of course to saint
louis under the
wealthy wing of rex singfield and these
are currently the top 10 players in the
united states so you can see some very
very strong names fabiana corwana wesley
so
linear dominguez hikaru nakamura jeffrey
young sam shankland ray robson
gatakonsky
samuel sebian alexander ronichuk and
darius schwirtz
but as only four players are for example
playing in the
uh olympiad 11 will be quite a
contribution to this team
and they were forced to be reckoned with
even without him but now it's going to
be
pretty crazy but even that doesn't mean
anything as
as we've seen in in the olympiad but 11
led his team to victory
three times so far in 2006 2008 and 2012
but the game i've prepared for you here
is actually from the 2004 olympiad
uh but it features a most uh wonderful
game where 11 employs uh
none other than the marshall gambit one
of my favorite openings
uh so let's check that out and see uh
how the game wins so uh he's facing
russian grand master alexander shabalov
uh and he opens with e4 as i already
mentioned that there will be uh
a marshall gambit on the board uh we
have e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and now bishop to b5 the
real lopez is on the board we have a6
morpheus defense pushing the bishop back
and the bishop to a4
uh knight to f6 we have castles and
bishop to a7 so
yeah everything is a fairly standard i'm
sure you guys know all about this rook
to e1 we have b5 chasing the bishop back
bishop b3
and now black castles we have c3 and now
we reach the famous position where frank
marshall
long long time ago employed his famous
weapon
against jose royal capoblanca and that
is d5 the start of the martial attack
and this is one of the fiercest attacks
in all of chess
so black is offering a pawn for some
very very exciting counterplay and the
white accepts this as
it's fine to accept the pawn so e
captures
uh we have knight captures and now
knight captures on e5
grabbing that pawn with knight captures
and rook characters now with a double
attack on this knight
and here you can play a lot of stuff you
can play uh
you have to defend the knight obviously
you can play c6 you can play bishop to
b7 to defend it you can move the knight
by knight to f6 and while all of these
moves are played c6 is
to date the the most popular one so c6
defending the knight
and now uh the rook will be will be
attacked with
something like bishop to d6 so the rook
goes back immediately we'll rook to e1
and bishop to d6 now putting some
pressure
on the h2 pawn queen to h4 is to be
expected so here
uh shabbalov goes g3 now preventing the
queen's uh
uh reach of the h4 square we have bishop
to f5 now
developing the light square bishop and
only now d4 you could play d4 before g3
but like i said then you allow queen to
sort of queen to h4
and maybe uh maybe not the the greatest
of ideas so here
queen to d7 uh now preparing to counter
those light squares
uh as this is often the plan you want to
play bishop g4 uh force
the the white queen to move maybe get
bishop f3 and play queen h3 and then
deliver checkmate with queen g2
that's the the the short plan but it's
uh much harder to achieve this of course
if white plays well
so bishop to e3 continuing development
and now
rook eta e8 uh now black's uh
black's pieces are already very nicely
developed while white still has to
decide what to do with the knight and
with the rook on a1 so here at night
uh knights to d2 the knight is coming to
f3
and bishop to g4 now preventing that as
the queen on d1 is under attack and here
we have queen to b1
uh interestingly a year before this game
was played in 2003
peter lake who had this position against
vishwanathan and leko played queen to c2
here and anand
won this game with the black pieces so
uh probably shabbat knows of this game
he tries queen to b1 now
uh and now uh bishop to f5 again
attacking the queen
and now queen back to c1 and only now
rook to e6 now 11 shifts the rook into
the attack a nice rook cliff the rook is
coming to
h6 or g6 for the moment not h6 but maybe
in the future
and it is uh only now as of move 18 that
this position has never been reached
again
so here white continues developing
knights to f3
and now bishop to g4 threatening to to
capture the knight we have knight to g5
attacking the rook and 11 moves it we
have rook to g6
and now the well what do you do here
best for white is knight to e4 but it's
uh
not an easy decision to make because of
course black wants to play this
this and checkmate you so of course you
cannot go bishop grabbing here because
queen h3 and you just lost the game
so what you would have to do here is go
even further back with the knight
knights to d2 and now push this bishop
back and
if you are able to eliminate this bishop
or at least make it uh
less powerful that will be good for you
but you know it's
always uh said that the hardest move to
find is with the knight back and
especially
uh uh move with the knight back twice so
that that's even harder
but here shabala played f3 and this is
something that simply will not
do so here feel free to pause the video
and find the
the winning idea for 11 while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not going back
uh the bishops never go back the bishops
go forward
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop captures an
f3 this is only the first pawn sacrifice
uh the first piece sacrifice
and this one well it can be captured but
it doesn't have to be captured
just give me a second
sorry about that uh could have been
something important
uh so bishop captures on f3 and now you
could capture it or
you could uh just say okay i played this
uh
on purpose and it's actually upon
sacrifice maybe i'll just play
rook to f1 and claim i now have the
semi-open
f file for the for my rook the bishop
will be under attack
and so on uh but white decides to
capture it so shabala grabs the bishop
knight captures on f3 but now 11
continues happily sacrificing the bishop
bear so bishop captures on g3 so a very
nice bishop pair sacrifice
and here this sacrifice you do not want
to accept it but again if you don't
accept it you you just uh
forced the to play in in a worse
position so here shabalov tries
uh to accept the the sacrifice and try
to hold on to everything but now
rook captures on g3 with check king to
f2
and now queen to h3 now 11 is
threatening queen to g2 checkmate but
also if you defend that just
rook captures on f3 so you cannot defend
against both so king to e2
uh start uh the white king starts
running away but now
uh queen the g2 with check uh and here
eleven just wants to trade down into
into a superior game uh although rook to
g to check
is even more potent i will show it
because it's a lot of fun uh point is
now the d3 square is not available to
you if you go king v3 queen f5 is now
checkmate
so you cannot uh go there with the king
uh if you go
king to d1 then just queen captures an
f3 so here you would have to block with
the bishop
but then after bishop to f2 you have
opened up the e file for this rook to
come into the attack and now
white's position just uh collapses but
there there's a lot to consider a lot to
calculate so 11 uh decided to go for the
for the more straightforward line queen
to g2 with check
king to d3 now this is possible uh and
now queen captures an f3 regaining
material
and now you'll see what this is all
about so white is up material and white
decides to eliminate
one of the attackers bishop captures on
the e5 c captures on d5
it's a very good general rule to use in
chess
when you're up material you should trade
down however here it's not so simple
white is up material
white is up a full piece but there's the
problem of the rook on a1 and uh
if you're unable to develop this rook
you're actually not up material you you
are down material you're up material
uh uh for you know as you are
up material but you're really not so
here came the c2
uh trying to to run away with the king
here rook the g1
uh was maybe a better idea trying to
trade off as much uh
as many of those attackers as possible
so king c2 and now
rook ate the e8 uh rook eat rook the e8
just getting another attacker into the
game threatening to win material here so
bishop d2
uh and now queen to d3 with check king
to b3
and now rook to b8 preparing to bust
open here the position with wood moves
like b4
so here we have a3 preventing that and
now rook the g2
putting more pressure on this bishop and
also the other rook
will definitely join in the attack so
here rook to d1
defending and now rook to e8 this rook
is now coming to e2 and it's going to be
impossible to hold on to everything with
queen to b1 now offering a queen trade
11 of course not
interested in accepting that so queen c4
check king to c2 and now
rook e to e2 uh and now
if you look at this position yes white
is still up a piece uh but
the rook on a1 ah simply uh simply a
completely useless piece this is like uh
i don't know this is like having uh like
50 bitcoins somewhere and you don't have
the keys to your wallet so that that's
how use
useful this rook is so here b3 uh
pushing back the queen and trying to
somehow develop
develop that rook into the game we have
queen back to c8 and now queen to b2
now the rooks might be able to uh get
activated but there's the problem of
this bishop so
maybe first rook to c1 and then you're
going to play king to b1
maybe something like that but of course
11 will not wait for that he starts
pushing the
uh his past h pawn and now this is a
very strong pass pawn
uh white what can white do here white
starts by playing a4 maybe you can
activate the rook via the a file
so 11 continues pushing h4 we have a
captures on b5
a captures on b5 and now queen to a3
now hoping for queen to a8 to get the
queens off the board and then maybe
maybe white can start playing this game
11 of course not interested in allowing
this we
have queen sorry not that obviously uh
we have queen to f5 this comes with
check and now king to c1 you have to
keep an eye on the bishop there is no
other move
so h3 continuing to push this pass pawn
and now
queen to a8 with check came to h7 and
now
queen to d8 so now the rook is coming to
a8
and you have to be careful you always
have to be uh
well be mindful of this queen page for
check if it does anything
but lemon says nope that doesn't do
anything just h2
uh we have rooked the a8 now uh going
for queen to h8 to check
uh but 11 says that's not a problem i'm
just going to prepare the queening of my
pawn
and that's it what can you play here
queen the h8 was played with
check king to g6 and now rook the a6
with
check here 11 just blocked with f6 and
now
there are no more checks the e8 square
is covered by the rook so it's not a
problem
so here white tried rook to a7
threatening rook captures on g7 with
checkmate uh but it is it is far too
late for such things we have rook
captures on d1 with
check king captures and now the
brilliant finisher h1
queen and it was in this position uh on
move 47
that alexander shabala resigned in the
game and what what an impressive victory
for for levin rnn
uh here you resign because it's check
and also
if you do if you don't uh capture
black's queen black will capture the
white queen so there's really no option
here you have to capture the queen
and then the idea is uh just queen to be
to with
check and now of course if you move the
king then uh
the the queen comes off the board but
you don't really have a a better
decision because
if bishop the c2 blocking then queen to
c2 is just
checkmate so here uh you would be forced
actually to give up your queen captures
captures and then there's no
no point in playing this yes you do have
a rook and a bishop for a queen
but it's uh the white's pieces are so
discoordinated you're also down upon
it's just too easy to play this so to
give you an example like
you could go after the pawn maybe to
create a pass pawn but just
a queen g2 check and after king d1
there's again nothing for you to do
black can just push another pass pawn to
victory
you can never capture this if you
capture then queen to f1 check
just uh picks up that rook so also not
possible
uh so after this h1 a promotion to a
queen alexander caballo resigned and
and and and then excellent victory for
for levan arnhem
uh so a great great game definitely we
haven't shown this one so hope you guys
enjoyed it as i always enjoy a good game
featuring the marshall gambit and uh
yeah that will be fun to see what uh
what
levin will do now that he joins the team
of the united states
and how will that uh that improve their
presence in the olympiad and uh
well uh uh in general
uh sure that's the game uh and the news
uh hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank
bonecloudchest.com uh harry reeves uh
the artist
drago start made even and christopher
denninger for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day